Die Fragen könnten auch langweilig und
enttäuschend sein, nicht meine Antwort. Entschuldigung,
das ist reines Ritual, warum machen sie
diese
Schweiz immer ernsthaft zu
meinem Lieblingsland in Europa,
aber Sie wissen warum,
weil es hier Ordnung ist,
ich als Linker, ich hasse das,
Sie sollten den schmutzigen Teil besuchen  von der
stadt bekommst du ein authentisches
filmgefühl ich will keine echtheit ich will dass die
dinge funktionieren
unvorstellbar schlimmer als der tod
klick
glück ist pech glück ist für idioten
ich glaube an kreativität ich glaube an
kreative unzufriedenheit für mich
ist glück
diese stille
dummheit blick  ist für mich
eine
kompromissformel und
ich hätte große angst glucky creek zu sein es ist
furchtbar
aber
ich bin in der jetzigen situation absolut
gegen patrifismus
denn vergiss nie aggressor
will immer frieden
frieden bedeutet er hat es geschafft
liber
liebe ist für mich die
ultimativste begrenzung  zu einer Person, die Sie
leidenschaftlich lieben, was bedeutet, dass
Sie Ihr Leben vernachlässigen, wird alles
andere zu einer Katastrophe  Das Liebesleben ist eine
Katastrophe,
dachte
es existiert nicht und das macht
es so
dramatisch, dass es nicht in unser Universum integriert werden kann.
Political Correctness
Sie wissen, wer mir die beste Antwort auf
Political Correctness gegeben hat. Meine alte Geschichte, in der ich vor
Jahren einmal
in Montana war  bei einer diskussion waren ein paar
indianer da und als ich das sagte
hat mich natürlich jemand korrigiert nein nein ureinwohner
es war ein indianer da der
mich sofort ansah er sagte nein wir
hassen es indianer genannt zu werden
denn das gegenteil von natur ist
kultur was ist  du dann
rechner amerikaner oder was er sagte ich ziehe es vor
indisch genannt zu werden weil in diesem fall
zumindest mein name ein denkmal für weiße
namen ist die dummheit weißer männer die dachten
das indien woher
die politische korrektheit kam
weil es nicht wirklich radikal ist es ist eine
falsche radikalität  lasst uns ein spiel spielen, um
radikal zu sein, damit wir nicht wirklich
etwas ändern müssen
philosophie
sehr interessant, ich freue mich
beruflich darauf
in einer sehr schwierigen Epoche wie unserer
heute leben,
in der die
Philosophie
Teil unseres täglichen Lebens wird, nehmen Sie an der
Debatte über Pandemie teil, sollten wir Masken tragen
oder nicht, schränken Masken unsere Freiheit ein, dies
war im Grunde eine implizite philosophische
Debatte darüber,
wie viel von unserem Alltag genommen werden kann
leben unsere manieren frei zu bleiben wenn man
über abtreibung debattiert dort
beginnt das leben und so weiter und so weiter so denke ich
, weil traditionelle weisheiten immer mehr an kraft
verlieren, müssen
sich selbst gewöhnliche menschen
wissentlich oder unwissentlich mit philosophischen
fragen auseinandersetzen
kapitalismus
das größte gestaltsystem  In der
gesamten Menschheitsgeschichte müssen wir
darüber nachdenken, aber der einzige Weg zur Freiheit führt
über den Kapitalismus
Karl Marx Sehr interessanter Heiler von Hegel,
aber obwohl er einige Dinge sah, die
Hegel nicht
mochten, gibt er eine sehr hegelianische Interpretation des
Kapitals als Selbst
-idee reproduzieren aber ich denke heute ist die zeit um von marx zu hegel zurückzukehren
realität
ich denke realität
ich bin kein
subjektives ideali  Aber ich denke, die Realität
ist eine symbolische Funktion,
nicht in dem Sinne, dass ich sie erschaffe, sondern in
dem Sinne, dass es eine wirkliche Ursache gibt, die nicht darstellbar ist,
aber was wir
als wirklich da draußen erleben,
ist immer
begrenzt, konstruiert als unser
symbolisches Universum
[Musik]